on your screen right now are thousands
of ancient galaxies
brought to you in one of the first five
images taken by the james webb space
telescope or jwst
the region captured here spans as much
of the sky as a grain of sand would
cover if held at arm's length
the farther away these galaxies are the
longer their light took to reach us
this view reaches back more than 13
billion years into the past but jwst
isn't just witnessing history it's
making it
launched in 2021 after more than 25
years of planning the space telescope
traveled 1.5 million kilometers away
from earth to give us a new view of the
universe
this is the karina nebula
jwst can see deep into its clouds and
reveals stars as they form
our sun was actually born in a cloud
like this
here we see the opposite end of a star's
life cycle through the southern ring
nebula
at its center a star has run out of fuel
and partially exploded leaving behind
beautiful ripples
these ripples are one of the main ways
that elements like carbon an important
building block for planets and life get
spread throughout the universe
next is a group of galaxies called
stefan's quintet
as these galaxies fall closer to each
other they're starting to swirl like
water going down a drain
with jwst we can see thousands of other
galaxies in the background too lastly
jwst measured light from a planet called
wasp 96b orbiting another star in the
milky way the signal shows that this
particular planet a gas giant like
jupiter has clouds
the telescope will look for similar
signals from rocky planets that could
potentially host life these images are
just a glimpse of what's to come
jwst did all of this in a matter of days
it has enough fuel for 20 years
[Music]